Mikell keg back here on the show how are
you Michael quart wretched are you
surprised about the Girardi firing I'm
surprised that it was the Yankees
decision that's really surprising to me
I always thought there was a possibility
that Joe would walk away and you know
just take a little bit of a deep breath
for a couple of years and then rejoin
the fray but the fact that the Yankees
you know they sent out a release saying
that they're going to move in another
direction so they want to make it very
clear that they're the ones who made the
decision that's surprising so why did
they do that you think trying to read
the tea leaves I would think that either
the relationship with with Cashman was
becoming a bit frayed or tense or maybe
the Yankee front office felt that the
relationship between Joe Girardi and the
players was not as good as it could be
you know Joe Torre had the respect and
love of his players Girardi has the
immense respect of his players I'm not
sure that there's a great affection
there you know Joe's not a warm and
cuddly guy and maybe because the team is
so numbers and analytic driven they felt
that they needed somebody that could
also have some warmth attached to it
because Joe was all about the black and
white all about the numbers well I know
he had that binder that always drove me
nuts that he always looked at and then
made a decision that was a head
scratcher to say the least but when it's
all said and done there were more wins
than losses and you know I that it's
interesting you mentioned Torre Michael
because the 95 Yankees who this team
might resemble most as opposed to the 96
Yankees that won at all had Buck
Showalter as their manager and they
turned the page from him and they got
Joe Torre and then all of a sudden a
dynasty broke out do you see something
similar potentially in this whole
scenario I want to see exactly who they
bring in but certainly the talent base
is there that's why you know if Joe
walked away I would have been surprised
on that end that somebody would walk
away from the potential to round out the
resume and go to the Hall of Fame you
know he might have two more
championships here because this team
that you saw it's probably the worst
team the eighties are gonna have for the
next five years that's how much talent
is in the pipeline
this team is primed to win championships
they are they're built that way but one
thing I would say to you risks you know
you hated the binder oh we've been Billy
Martin and I walking through that door
the next guy they hire is going to be a
slave to the binder that's who they will
insist on because this is an analytics
team this is a team that the numbers are
crunched by very bright people upstairs
and those numbers are expected to be put
to work by the manager the manager does
not go by the gut at all if he has a
book that says that Sabathia zra rises
from 3.2 to 5.1 after 75 pitches
Sabathia is gonna be taken out after 75
pitches even if he looks great we've
seen it in the postseason so the next
manager is gonna be a numbers driven guy
as well Michael Kay yes Network also of
the Michael Kay show in New York City
here on the Rich Eisen show so who might
be walking through that door do you
think I mean that's a good question uh
it's gonna be a little bit of a battle I
would think because this is New York and
there's some Broadway to it so you would
think it's gonna be a big name or
somebody with a recognizable name but I
don't think that name was going to be
beholding the numbers so I'll throw a
couple of names at you Robb Thompson has
been the bench coach for Joe Girardi
he's been in the Yankee organization for
26 years is that a big enough name I
don't know Cashman certainly has a
relationship with him is Cashman said
that's going to be imperative in anybody
they hire Kevin longest free Kevin long
was a part of the Yankee organization
for a while before it was like those
hitting coach would they look at him I
know a guy that Brian Cashman has always
admired a guy like Pete mackanin
who was fired as the Phillies manager
and moved to the front office but
obviously could take another job he
could go if they want to go but that's
certainly not a big sexy New York name
but then the Mets went on got a guy
named Mickey Calloway that not too many
people know so you could make your own
name but I don't know if there's a favor
in the clubhouse right now I mean with
Tony Pena be considered Heep in a second
when you're already got the job maybe
maybe there's a manager that has a job
right now that could get out of the job
and take this one because I think this
is there's one of the great jobs and
sports that's available right now you
come into a ready-made situation with an
organization that's brimming with talent
so whoever gets it's gonna be a lucky
man how about this name three three
three words for Donald Arthur Mattingly
Michael I don't think so a lot of people
have asked that he finished a distant
third or when when they hired Girardi it
was Girardi first pinion and then
Mattingly so I don't think that Donnie
is that
numbers driven analytical guy I think he
is certainly adapted to it
but I just I can't see that happening
because consider this there were two
players in the history of the Yankees
when George Steinbrenner bought them and
on them that he considered sons one was
Mattingly and one was Jeter I mean he
really considered them his third and
fourth sons and George was still alive
when this decision was made to hire
Girardi so if they if they couldn't get
Mattingly to be hired with George still
alive I just don't think it's gonna
happen now
and isn't amazing that one son is now
the owner of the team that he's the
manager of GM it is Michael cave yes
network joining me here and now let's
talk a little bit about last night
I mean the Yankees were able to keep
Springer down and Altuve is gonna Altuve
but this team what it did last night
against that Dodger bullpen really I
think might be an awakened World Series
giant what do you think Michael K well
certainly they needed that game you
didn't want to go back to Houston down
Oh to but you know I looked at it
another way rich their bullpen is
terrible it is Castro's that's true they
almost maybe it's just a blip on the
radar screen for the Dodgers I thought
that Roberts probably pushed the
envelope two months trying to get two
innings out of Jansen I think the whole
thing that messed him up was the pitcher
that he brought in that threw just four
pitches that's not the way he planned it
and then he had to go tomorrow after
that so I think that messed up the whole
timeline but I still don't think the
Astros have enough bullpen to make this
work that's true
I mean they they almost blew the second
two-run lead that they got in the extra
innings last night almost blew that one
and then if that game went into the 12th
inning I don't know who the heck would
have pitched for the Houston Astros
you know who probably would had a grab a
starter that that they you know from
Game four I would think that's the only
thing I could think so now it's the best
of five with three next three in the
juice box down in Houston who do you
think wins this World Series Michael I
think I picked the Dodgers at six I'll
stay with that one thing you know we go
back to talking analytics and I talked
about this on
show yesterday take a lot of the fun
away from baseball really has you know
the arguments and stuff like that
because all these managers have this
data that that tells you why they make
these whacky decisions which Hill should
not have been pulled after four innings
and that's set up everything we had an
overuse Jansen so it's strange I mean
these guys go strictly by the numbers
that's the only way it's going to be
allowed and the the stars of the team
are no longer the loop pinellas you know
throwing bases and Billy Martin it's the
front office so you don't even see those
are the guys making all the calls well I
mean just again because you're so close
to it and you see it and how it does
actually manifest itself in a decision
what would possibly have been the
numbers that told Dave Roberts to pull
Rich Hill in the middle of a game like
that the numbers would be that third
time through the order the numbers go up
exponentially and you know we saw it
with Sabathia during the postseason
where they took him out against
Cleveland when he shouldn't have been
taken out in the 83 lead and that that
was the game where he didn't you know
Girardi didn't challenge the hit by
pitch so those are the numbers that they
just live and die by and and here's what
the manager is risking rich if you don't
take them out and then everything falls
apart
then you have to answer to the the front
office geniuses and I don't say that in
a pejorative way these people with
geniuses why didn't you take him out
we've given you the data you have to
take him out and I just think that the
game has moved away from trust your eyes
I mean Dave Roberts knows when the guy
is losing his stuff you were watching
the game I was watching the game was
Rich Hill losing his stuff to your eye
not to mine so I just think that a lot
of the fun of baseball has been taken
away by all the analytics and all the
ships and all the bullpen moves and
stuff like that it's not the same
although that was a fun game yesterday
Michael always enjoy our chats let's
chat down the line maybe next time when
the Yankees name a manager and and and
in between I always love chatting with
you anytime rich thank you right back at
you at real Michael Kay on Twitter for
more Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
channel 239 on DirecTV
the Rich Eisen show app